you
combining the traditional and the modern
is the concept behind flowers for
slovakia a young design project from
Bratislava the collective of students
and established designers is presenting
its first furniture collection at the DM
Y International Design Festival in
Berlin these objects are so special
because you can really see a poetic
moment interest so you can feel that
this is something some symbioses of this
very old traditional pieces that gap
already lost we found them in some barns
and some sellers plus this unique design
pieces from Vietnam so we have this very
modern design part and that is very hand
crafted old traditional things and we
put them together a lost and found
collection has been nominated for a d my
award for innovative concepts the jury
includes some top names
you feel very delighted very honored
that we are even got that we received
this nomination for the design award
it's a very young project we have put a
lot of energy into it but now we see
that the project is really working five
years ago the designers laws kempe quedo
allah and makalah nikova prepared the
ground for flowers for slovakia in the
capital bratislava their objective was
to develop contemporary designs that
would incorporate elements of their home
country's history for their first
project in 2011-12 design students join
them in creating a glass collection
inspired by slovakian fairy tales what
is the connection point between handle
with care and the current collection is
the topic of Slovakia and the topic of
tradition work on the current furniture
collection began in July last year the
project initiators took some students
along to an old village in the outback
of Slovakia where they looked around for
old pieces of furniture and acquainted
themselves with traditional
cabinetmaking methods
I feel folk art installer here is in a
way shared with the region we are in
with Central Europe we were using very
simple things made from the resources we
had like food and linen and in a way
this simplicity is very charming and I
think this is something between did not
it is not very much seen in Slovak
design and we would like to wake it up
the 15 design students modify the
historical pieces for several weeks
adding elements by the renowned Swiss
furniture maker Vita the final result
was the 17 handmade one-of-a-kind pieces
of the Lost and Found collection
I think this objects are very unique and
very authentic this is maybe stopped
because of our international design
sorry of operative anything you have to
be authentic and very very yogic to be
interesting for audience back in Berlin
more than 150 exhibitors from the world
over are presenting their latest
creations in a hangar at the
decommissioned Tempelhof Airport the
Slovakian designers are among the
frontrunners for the award what is
designed for Bassitt limbs good design
is supposed to improve living conditions
meaning an improved function a great
aesthetic along with a cultural
inspiration unequipped and this design
group has succeeded in breathing new
life into household objects into old
chairs for example or old cradles and in
combining them with a typical elements
by the vitra company which is known for
high quality design and that motivated
us to nominate this group for the award
what you've yet equal policy the DM Y is
one of Germany's biggest arenas for
young product designers and an
opportunity for up-and-coming designers
to network we don't know what our next
season will look like which kind of
materials we will use but this is this
one thing is really for sure we really
want to create new unique objects again
and we want to find really highly
motivated people it's a formula that's
proving successful after Berlin the
collection will be moving on to London
and Milan
you